alright this is a pepper panic saga
level 290 walkthrough tutorial video a
couple members in our group today we're
having trouble getting past this level I
haven't got a chance to write the tips
yet so I'm going to go ahead and make
one of these videos real quick and then
add some tips later well I just loaded
the game and I got a really nice board
layout to start you can see over here
that i have my l i intended to say that
if you don't have this you know you
probably want to go over here and use
your quit button until you get at least
like the gaps that you need to set up
and out there are seven matches they're
all hard you only have 28 move so it's a
good idea to start off with a board that
will at least give you the chance to set
up the first though because once you
start growing peppers and the and the
cat starts taking them away it gets a
little bit harder to set things up so i
don't have to start over here but keep
that in mind if you're having trouble
completing this level so we'll go ahead
and make our first out and you can see
over here we also have the tea that we
need next so we'll go ahead and make
that
alright so now we need another L you saw
what the gap for the owl looks like we
need a pair we need a pair go in this
direction and then we need a pair that
is sitting catty-corner to that so here
you can see we have part of one we don't
have any red pepper to bring down to get
in here and this one's going to get
taken away anyways so that's not very
good we have part of one here if we can
bring a blue pepper down this way
that'll be helpful so I'm going to go
ahead and just I'm not I'm going to
focus over here and I can see that the
cat is going to take this red pepper
here so these yellows are going to clear
out naturally so I'm going to go ahead
and work above that and see if I can get
a a blue pepper to fall into this row so
i can make either one of these matches
here i'm going to go ahead and pull the
green one down because that will get a
new pepper to fall and we'll see if it's
blue or not
okay so now we have a blue one that we
need up here but this is blocked
completely so let's look around and see
what else we have we have part of the
the thing that we need here we got to
billing this way and one going that way
with with the final one in place there
if I if I match this this it's going to
explode this blue one which is going to
drop this green one to where it's going
to be grabbed but we'll have another
green one below so out of all the
choices we have I think this would be
the best match and then we'll see how
things develop after we make it oh that
was kind of a mistake you can see but
that's why this is it's up level it's a
little bit hard to keep track of where
everything is going to go and you know
you have enough moves that you can
afford a couple of mistakes like that it
shouldn't ruin your chances so at this
point we we don't have the the gap that
we need set up anywhere it gets a little
bit harder to see them whenever
everything is when all the peppers are
grown like this but we'll go ahead and
see if we can't bring some peppers
together
let's look for
whenever it gets like this it's probably
not a bad idea to just start a panic and
clear things out of it you can catch the
matches in the Cascades sometimes
I'm just trying to see where the best
place to start exploding things will be
I'm going to go ahead and do it over
here the green are pretty grown and
we'll see how things fall into place
he's going to clear a bunch of peppers
in this row so we really don't know what
the board is going to look like until
after that happened
alright so that doesn't change anything
a whole lot except for now the yellow
peppers are are the quickest way to
start a training chain reaction
see we got four stage for two states for
the stage one here so that's going to
create an explosion and if that doesn't
go all the way to a panic which it might
or might not then we can go ahead and
start the yellow on the next move so
we'll go ahead and do that but that is
going to start though we caught one of
our l's there and that just reaffirms
the reasoning behind when you don't have
the gaps you need to start a little bit
of action and get things to move around
all right now we need to look for our
gap for the tea the gap of the t's a
little bit different because we need to
we need to have a pair like this
basically so this looks like our best
spot at the moment so what I'm going to
do is try to see if I can bring a yellow
pepper down into this blog
alright so that's closer but it's not we
can't move it if we if we match the
green it's going to bring oh yeah
actually if we this is this is fine if
we match the green here it's going to
make a t4 so that worked out well
alright so we have our L already set up
over here now we're going to wait till
this this is going to start another
reaction and clear the board out and be
able to look for another tea
alright so we have most of it right here
we see our gap this is what we want but
we also have the tea already there since
this one's going pretty smoothly I just
want to point out the fact that say this
green tea wasn't here already what we
could do is we can match the Greens
they're going to combine together to one
the yellow ones going to move to the
left they're going to combine to one
that's going to sit here and the blue is
going to sit right on top so you can see
right there we would have been able to
set up the tea for the very next match
but we don't have to do that in this
case so we'll go ahead and make our tea
and now we have to make a five pepper
straight line match so a lot of us got a
crash course in this one with the with
the level 259 the old way that it used
to be but basically what we're looking
for is we're looking for a gap of a pair
of peppers like this one with a pepper
to the side that we can move into the
middle and as you can see right here we
can set this up right now we have a two
pepper at stage two of stage three and a
stage one that's going to add up to six
so that's going to give us a pepper
that's not going to explode it's going
to sit right where we want it to and
that's going to drop this other pair of
blues down and it's going to sit right
on top and now we can make our five
pepper match and finish the level
so hopefully what you take away from
that is is the most important thing is
finding those gaps and then working the
peppers you need into place it is one of
the more difficult match pattern levels
that they've come out with because the
cats involved but you can definitely
help yourself out by you know getting a
good start using the quit button in the
beginning if you need to and then always
looking for the gaps first and try to
move things into place if you can't move
them it's good to clear things out and
get a new start and hopefully that'll
get you through it before too long all
right